objet de toutes les polémiques depuis le
début de la pandémie
le masque fait son grand retour dans les
rues de plus d'un tiers des
municipalités françaises
ce samedi toulouse a fait le show à
détendre le port du masque à l'ensemble
de son territoire
nous avons vu au cours de ces dernières
semaines
chaque roi sur une façon très rapide la
pénétration du virus au sein de la
population toulousaine et c'est ce qui a
conduit avec un dépassement du child
alert c'est ce qui a conduit à prendre
cette décision
dans la ville rose la décision est
plutôt bien vu par les habitants c'est
pareil alors c'est pour la santé de tous
il faut le porter c'est normal
et j'avoue que l'extérieur c'est un peu
vrai patron de cette équipe sans voix
bon après ça va être un réflexe
apprendre à dire au quotidien non c'est
pas très contraignant
c'est un peu chaud mais s'est fait
quelques mois qu'on a l'habitude même un
port du masque qui s'étend à l'intérieur
dès le 1er septembre celui-ci sera
obligatoire en entreprise et dans les
établissements scolaires pour les élèves
de 11 ans et plus un protocole renforcé
pour éviter un report de la rentrée
comme l'a expliqué le ministre de
l'éducation nationale nous voulons
évidemment que l'éducation soit pour
tous et qu' il n'y ait pas de
renforcement des inégalités ou des
difficultés scolaires du fait des
circonstances sanitaire donc j'ai deux
impératifs sont complémentaires c'est
protéger tous les élèves et les adultes
mais aussi assurer l'éducation de tous
et c'est un point fondamental c'est
pourquoi la rentrée aura bien lieu comme
prévu le 1er septembre à lille lyon
marseille ou paris
ce sont pour le moment seulement les
zones à forte fréquentation qui font
l'objet de ces mesures sanitaires comme
la butte montmartre où les abords de la
tour eiffel depuis juillet
l'organisation mondiale de la santé oms
a admis que la transmission du coc u19
par voie aérienne ne peut pas être
exclue